which will where's little Tay in 40
years that's what I want to know where's
lighthouse where else after Kanye's
children she's gonna she's gonna be next
I mean that's an interesting thought
exercise though like where do you go
down from Donald Trump I mean because
the progression has to go down right
wait we all does it because I remember
when Bush was president and like are
talking to reporters Bush used to do
this thing where he would carry around a
biography of Dean a jusen for weeks and
weeks and weeks just to prove to
reporters that he could read and we all
used to joke with each other like
nobody-nobody stupider than this is ever
gonna be president and now you know you
look back and and bushes you know he's
like Einstein compared to trump I had a
joke that I did back in my Netflix
special from 2005 when when Bush was in
office where it was a bunch of people
we're trying to figure out how dumb
people are and they're like the only way
they like there's speculation like let's
get a smart guy to act dumb like no no
you got to get a real dumb guy otherwise
we'll never know we've gotta have a real
dumb guy and then so they get the real
dumb guy and they put up do a bunch of
things you know they they vote them in a
second time and then some of the back of
the room goes I think we can go dumber
[Laughter]
we are right this is a bit from 2005 but
you know it's for 13 years later life
imitates art we went way dumber that's
right right well to allow seems super
reasonable in comparison to some of the
[ __ ] that Trump says in terms of like
Supreme Court rulings and like there was
a Supreme Court ruling that went against
Bush's way while he was in office and he
had a really reasonable response he was
like of course we're disappointed but we
have to abide by the court and their
ruling and you know I was like something
you would never hear Trump say yeah
never hear him say something like that
no absolutely I mean I look back and
Bush seems to me almost like a
Scandinavian statesman compared
it'll take she would go to the white
house too
you know a lot of people didn't want to
go to the White House for the
inauguration uh-huh okay we'll go she'll
go I mean the White House is good it's
gonna look like the White House and
idiocracy when she's when she's in there
right I mean it's it's it's it's gonna
be terrible but well that was a weird
time to write like during the
inauguration when know celebrities
wanted to go right dig out like really
weird like real [ __ ] on the outskirts
celebrities oh yeah
and there's the same thing with the RNC
I cover I remember I covered the RNC and
and and they had to have Scott Baio
do one of the first day speeches yeah it
was a huge supporter right but I mean I
know Scott know personally yeah it's
very nice guy I'm sure he is
I'm sure he is guy yeah yeah but that
was there that was there a list for the
Republican National Convention and side
of you know like Hannah Dee's right
those type fellas right right exactly
yeah yeah it's fascinating yeah it is
it's just it's just weird it's it just
seems like everything's off like we skip
dimensions we like jolted over there's a
Carlile world where things just don't
seem like at least things used to make
set like you'd be disappointed to this
guy one or you'd be disappointed that
the country was doing this or that we
were invading Iraq or whatever it was
but it would kind of seem like the world
right well this is it's kind of like
what we're talking about we were talking
about before I mean previously like the
entertainment industry politics was
tightly controlled by a small group of
cigar-chomping people who sat in the
back room and in both parties they they
had a they carefully outlined a sort of
narrow range of acceptable political
opinions and in one party you could be
all the way up to you know somebody like
Ron Paul but they tended to put somebody
like George Bush as the candidate
but you know there was no directly
appealing to the electorate and asking
them who they wanted to be the candidate
I mean Donald Trump is really the first
Internet president he completely
bypassed that entire oligarchy he didn't
have to go through you know the
priesthood to get to be President which
on the one hand is evidence of a good
thing because it's actually more
democratic than the the system was
before where it was pretty much closed
to everybody except for a few people who
paid their dues through the system but
Trump directly you know just by being
famous and just by attracting media
attention he was able to bypass all the
usual tests and bypass the parties you
know decision making process and he got
to be President but he's like little pay
right I mean he just represents the
dummer side of us as opposed to the more
enlightened side of us so it's it's hard
to know what to think about it I mean I
when I was covering and I thought on the
one hand this is evidence that you know
the electorate is breaking away from
being told who to vote for on the other
hand the first time they take at that
freedom out for a test drive this is
what they pick I mean I don't know at
least it throws a giant monkey wrench
into the gears right yeah absolutely it
certainly done that yeah but you know
what what the result of that will be is
is yet to be determined yet to be
determined yeah I mean it could be the
end of civil
that you know when I was covering the
the Trump run part of me wanted to write
it as a comedy like all the early
stories were like highly comic I was
trying to write about the funny aspect
of it and then after he became president
it's like well this is either the
funniest thing that's ever happened in
America or it's the end of civilization
right does that make it funnier that
it's the end of civilization I don't
know I mean you're the you're a comic I
should I should ask you but I don't know
either it's well it's it's all depending
upon how it plays out right I mean
civilizations have absolutely fallen in
the price with this idea that
civilization won't fall in my opinion is
a
to the people that live on the Big
Island thinking that the volcano won't
erupt again right right yeah exactly
happened it's going to happen again yeah
like so our ideas about maintaining
civilization are an attempt to prolong
this state or mitigate any possible
disastrous effects of collapse right but
it's going to fall apart of course yeah
it's an old system that was constructed
on Scrolls by people writing with
feathers I really have no idea what the
future had install right just we didn't
they didn't know what the future had in
store they had no idea they would have
been terrified by a toothbrush yes right
yeah well certainly by a [ __ ]
airplane and cellular communication and
this we live in a world that requires a
completely new set of rules and
guidelines